her family continues to be supported by
specially trained officers who update
her update the family daily
and support them in other ways
I want to take you through the
unprecedented number of inquiries that
the police team has been doing in the
last 11 days
we've received literally thousands of
pieces of information from the public
The Wider Community
Nicholas family and friends which we've
been combing through diligently
this means at the moment there are
around 500 active pieces of information
and lines of inquiry that we're working
on to try and find answers for Nicholas
family
we have a team of 40 or so detectives
under a senior investigating officer
working daily to comb through this
enormous amount of information
this is normal in a missing person
inquiry and does not indicate that there
is any suspicious element to this story
the inquiry team remains fully
open-minded to any information that may
indicate where Nicola is or what
happened to her
some of the the specific pieces of
information and the lines that require
that they've been undertaking include
house to house in the village
looking at CCTV
the various pieces of dash cam that have
been submitted to the inquiry
identifying and tracing and speaking to
key Witnesses a number of whom have come
into the inquiry and been spoken to and
given valuable information
digital and telephony this includes
Nicholas Fitbit and her mobile phone
which has been fully examined
and we've now identified around 700
vehicles that drove through the village
on that morning on the 27th of January
at around 9 10 9 15. and we're in the
process of speaking to all of those
drivers to try and find out if they have
any dash cam footage what they saw on
that day or anything else that may be of
value to the police inquiry
we remain very grateful to all of our
partners and The Wider Community for the
help they've given
in particular and I've mentioned some of
these in the past
this includes his Majesty's Coast Guard
Lancashire Fire and Rescue
Lancaster area and Bowland Mountain
Rescue
other forces and National experts in
different fields
as well as The Specialist Group
International for SGI
who have offered their assistance to the
family free of charge and have been
working under the direction of our local
police search teams to help us
our work around the search of the river
and the riverbank continues
and this includes many pieces of
different technical equipment including
sonar
pole cameras drones underwater drones
and so on
as well as specialist dogs
as I said on Friday
the river is a complex area to search
it's not a still water it's a
fast-flowing moving water that is tidal
in parts
and as acknowledged by some of the many
national search advisors and experts
that we've been Consulting throughout
this makes it particularly complex
we have already discounted particular
areas of the river
but as they are tidal we have researched
them to ensure that nothing has been
washed back into those search areas
this is why you may see some areas
already searched being researched for no
other reason than it is tidal
we have
six people searching the Riverbanks
every day
these are specially trained search
offices
who are very experienced both in missing
people inquiries and in other inquiries
who are systematically and methodically
searching the riverbank can be open
ground
we also have a number of divers from the
regional underwater search unit and they
are working with SGI and the other
partners that I have mentioned to search
the river itself
throughout this investigation as I've
said we remain fully open to any
information
any information that is credible and
factual
to try and Trace Nicola and bring
answers for her family
but it does remain our belief
that Nicola sadly fell into the river
and that this is a missing person
inquiry
and it is important to stress that any
information that comes in
that indicates otherwise is being
checked out all the time
and negated as each inquiry comes up
we're not closed in any way to any
particular line of inquiry and we remain
genuinely open to that
all these extensive inquiries however
have so far not found anything of note
any indications of physical objects in
the river such as natural debris trees
and the like
have been already identified by the
original divers undiscounted so further
sightings of that debris are only items
that we already knew were on the
riverbed or in the riverbank
we would ask that people in The Wider
Community particularly on social media
and online do not speculate as to what
may have happened to Nicola
this is particularly hurtful to her
family to children to her partner Paul
her parents her sister and her friends
because it's not helpful to them it's
distressing and it's distracting for the
police inquiry
nor is it helpful if people particularly
if they come from outside of the area
take it upon themselves
to take the law into their own hands by
trying to for example break into empty
property they may mean well
they may want to help
but they can help in
thinking back if they were in the area
to what information they may have of
relevance to the police
and holding the family in their thoughts
but we will not tolerate online abuse of
anyone including innocent Witnesses
of members of the family and friends of
local businesses
or of criminal damage or burglary
and we will be taking the strong line on
that as you would expect
we have engaged with and worked shoulder
to shoulder with a number of very
specific experts as I mentioned earlier
these include the National Crime agency
who have reviewed all of the policing
and have not identified any other lines
of inquiry other than what we had
already identified
likewise we are working with the
national search advisor the police
national search advisor who again has
not identified anything in the search
strategy or the search area the physical
parameters
that we have not already explored
and I say this to reassure the local
community in particular as well as
Nicholas family that all possible lines
of inquiry search or investigation are
being exhausted
I'm just going to reiterate for those
who may not have caught some of the
earlier detail some of the key
elements of this case that may jog
somebody's memory if they were about on
Friday morning the 27th of January
we know that Nicola was last seen on the
upper field next to the river wire here
in St Michaels at 9 10.
she had taken her spaniel Willow out for
a walk
and CCTV that we've looked at shows that
Nicola did not leave
either the allotment lane exit
of that Riverside area
nor the Rowan water Caravan Park which
has been discounted
nor any of the other locked or areas
covered by CCTV
as I've said Friday this only leaves the
path along garstang Lane onto the a586
which is not covered by CCTV
but the more of those 700 or so Vehicle
drivers that we can identify who can
confirm that they have neither CCTV
sorry dashcam footage or saw anything on
that morning will help us to close that
very small Gap
we can say with confidence therefore
that we believe Nicola remained in the
Riverside area
I understand that this is frustrating
for those observing the investigation
when the river has been searched and
Nicola has not been found
that does not mean however that Nicola
was not in the river at some point due
to the tidal flow of the river
for this reason our search of the river
and the Riverbanks extends
out to the Sea
particularly the area from not and out
towards more
so we continue to appeal for drivers on
that morning and I will remind people of
Nicholas description the clothing that
she was wearing
and her movements on that day
Nicola is a white lady five foot three
with shoulder-length brown hair
she speaks with an Essex accent
she was last seen wearing a knee-length
black gilet jacket and underneath an
Engelbert Strauss black long sleeve
jacket to the waist
she was wearing black jeans long green
walking socks tucked into her jeans
and green ankle length Wellies
she has her hair tied in a ponytail
and was wearing a pale blue Fitbit
I have a small number of detail extra to
the timeline that I provided on Friday
that fills in some of the gaps on the
morning that Nicola disappeared
they include that at 8 26 am
Nicola left her home address with her
children and I know there's been CCTV
images from her dash cam from her
doorbell footage sorry that had been
released that made your jog someone's
memory
at 8 40 Nicola dropped her children off
at school here in St Michael's
at 8 43 she was seen on the river path
towards the gate and the bench on the
lower field
at 8 47 someone who knows Nicola saw her
walking along the lower field with her
dog
and the two dogs briefly interacted
together
at 8 53 she sent an email to her boss
at 8 59 she sent a message to a friend
at 901 she logged onto a team's call
and at 9 10 we had the last confirmed
sighting of Nicola on the upper field
walking her dog
we know from telephony work that her
phone was located on the bench at 9 20.
at 9 30 the team's call ended but
Nicola's phone stayed logged in
and at 9 33 approximately her phone and
her dog were found by another Witness
who doesn't know her
I would ask people to dig back into
their memory 11 days ago to that morning
and to phone us on 101 or if the Society
of Nicola on 999
or I do now have an email address for
direct contact into the investigation
room
for us to receive email
details of this are published on our
website
it is Nicola bully spelled ey
investigation or one word Nicola bully
investigation
at lancashire.police.uk
Nicola bully investigation at
lancashire.police.uk
just want to end by
holding Nicholas family in our thoughts
this is a an agonizing time for them
particularly her two little girls who
are only six and nine
very very distressing for them not to
have found Nicola
and to ask everyone to remain
constructive
Cooperative with the inquiry
not to do anything that would thwart us
and hold us back from trying to find
Nicola as quickly as possible
to remain respectful to each other in
the search that's including the inquiry
team and the local people for whom this
is also very difficult
this is a tight-knit community of people
have come out in force as have our
partners and I would thank them again
very much for their work so far
thank you
I'm happy to take questions
told our channel that he did not believe
that that was in the water he sent me
involvement
how helpful is that for you when the
police are saying it's hypothesis is out
she somehow fell into the water and yet
you've got part of the team
investigating this case basically
contradicting effect
well I thank SGI for the help that
they've given to the team as I said
before our search has not found Nicola
in the river and then a research in
Parts by SGI found the same that does
not mean as I said a few minutes ago
that Nicola has not been in the river
and in the light of other inquiries
being discounted from the investigation
so far although we are keeping an
absolutely open mind to anything new
then clearly our main belief is that
Nicola did fall into the river
um clearly Mr folding isn't and isn't
included within all the investigation
detail any more than the members of the
public are that are briefing through
these sorts of press conferences so
um we would ask that we'd be allowed
time to continue with those inquiries
and to release to the public only what
is relevant for them at that time thank
you I'll just take another question
thank you Mr President Riley it's the
12th day
has been missing uh everyday concerns
will increase no doubt for everyone
how confident are you
that your team will find it clear alive
this is 12 days since Nicole has been
missing and clearly a 15 kilometer
stretch of the river is a complex
difficult and moving body of water to
search
I do believe that we will find Nicola
but the nature is a powerful force
changes our parameters constantly which
is why we are bringing in the number of
experts that we have so that all the
best brains and trained people in the
country can give us the absolute best
chance of finding Nicola thank you thank
you
well I don't have a number for you but a
number of vehicles have already
submitted dash cam footage we know that
around that number pass through the
village that morning clearly not
everyone has dash cam footage so uh it's
information is coming in in literally by
the hundreds if not thousands almost
every day and therefore it will take us
some time to Wade through that
information
second sorry
camera
well I'm not I'm I'm not going to talk
about
um sort of how that those vehicles have
been identified but suffice to say we
have identified them we are in the
process of writing to all of them to ask
them to come forward and either confirm
or or negate whether they have anything
that they could help us with
dogs well clearly not all drivers are
local so we are writing to all those who
aren't in the local area but as I said
before extensive house to house has been
done so they're in the village they will
have been spoken to thank you
history to stay
so she'll work for medicine
didn't leave
well obviously after the press
conference last week her friends and
family were very equipped to come back
and say actually there's a CCTV camera
that she's broken which we've seen a lot
of um the action of that day and has
been
um
observations made by other police
experts who basically said How Can the
police at this stage with the
information that's in the public therapy
that they've read about through
newspapers or not that how can they rule
out you know file play so I just wonder
what you would say to those concerns
raised by kind of other people who are
observing this case externally but also
because family and friends about you
know have all of those Avenues
thoroughly been attracted completely
been about that possible
as I said before we will not be
conducting all elements of the
investigation in the public eye you
would not expect us to that would not be
the normal way things are done anyway
but I would like to reassure the
community that nothing in this
investigation so far
it has been checked out if it's come
into it suggesting crime it has been
checked out and discounted so every
single potential third-party line of
inquiry any potential suspicious or
criminal element has been looked at and
discounted now people who observe and
make comment on it in the media
um even if they have experience of
placing clearly are not in the inquiry
team and will not be privy to all of
that but the fact that the National
Crime agency peer review has
um absolutely
um wholeheartedly
um not identified any other line of
inquiry that we have not already started
looking at or completed should give
reassurance to The Wider public
sort of detail have you searched wider
well I'm not able to give exact
distances from the river to the
riverbank but clearly if Nicholas
entered the water and got into distress
and ended up on the riverbank
um you know struggling to cope with the
fast-moving water then clearly the
riverbank the immediate river banks have
been our main area of search but as I
think I said last Friday we've searched
within a mile radius of the point that
she last went missing and the publicity
has been such now that I think local
Anglers
wildfowlers people enjoying the
countryside dog walkers local residents
people who work in the local area
will be very very aware of Nicholas
description of this case of all the
publicity that's been generated and
we'll be looking out in those wider
areas thank you
that remains ongoing but nothing so far
that has indicated any particular
helpful piece of information
thank you thank you
I'm not able to give very specific
um details of CCTV beyond the local
Village I am aware what's been done in
the local Village but everything of
relevance to the river and the Riverside
is being considered so I'm sure that is
as well thank you hello
the river how's that continuing to be
scanned and checked over by the
inspection research teams how much extra
resources it could engage do you expect
for you to other lines to inquiry
well as I said the team of detectives
are a number around 40 that is under
constant review so if the search area
becomes too wide or the investigation
too complex as the senior investigating
officer over that inquiry team will
immediately ask for further resources
you know we're a reasonably sized Force
we are very used to bringing in offices
from other parts of the county this is
clearly garnering National publicity and
we will be very quick to move them in if
we need to and if we have to go to
Regional or even National support we're
very open to being led by the facts to
putting whatever is needed to this
investigation to it but I am satisfied
with assurances from the senior
investigating officer that that she has
all of the investigation resources that
she needs at this time
I'll just take the gentleman behind you
then I'll come back to you no problem
you mentioned that Amazon in this case
has been transferring these properties
well there are some properties along the
Riverside which are empty or derelict
um and
um whilst it may be well intentioned
that people think that that could be a
line of inquiry
um I would ask them to desist from doing
that in some cases it may be criminal of
the breaking in and causing damage or
committing a burglary we have gone into
derelict property including ones on the
Riverside any under renovation that were
empty with the commission of those
owners and their knowledge we have
searched houses
matching that sort of profile on the
River Bank including the grounds
because there is no criminal element yet
identified and we don't expect there to
be in this inquiry then we're not
starting to go into houses uh because
that's not where the inquiry is leading
us thank you
same with health because nobody's seen
her leaving this class and main entrance
or episode doesn't mean that she
couldn't attack is there any chance that
Nicola could be left by that way either
by herself or with somebody else yes
that is a possibility but that's why we
appeal for drivers to come forward to
try and close off that Avenue or to at
least explain and negate any sightings
on that lane
um the lane between the Riverside on
garstang Lane onto the a586 isn't long
people may have forgotten they may have
been away on holiday and miss much of
this publicity so if that is you and
you've returned from holiday or return
from an absence uh and this this
incident has sort of largely passed you
by till now I would ask you to think
back to Friday the 27th and whether you
were on GAR stand Lane and help us
exactly close that Gap thanks
we'll stop searching the river when all
the national expert advice and our own
staff confirmed to us that there is
nothing further to be gained by doing
that however that does not mean that
other inquiries might not continue so
I've mentioned already that the search
is extended as far as the sea more can
be for those who know it is a very wide
Bay and the area from not end towards
Morecambe is particularly rural so there
will be other elements that will remain
being searched people might not see the
river itself being searched but the
inquiry team
continues to work really diligently far
into the evening every single day to try
and close anything else off